more communal violence and hate speech
in india and a prime minister under
pressure to stop them opposition parties
are accusing him of staying silent but
will he act and what will be the fallout
of rising hate speech on india's future
this is inside story
hello and welcome to the program i'm kim
vinnell
india's history contains centuries of
diversity and coexistence between
different groups but its present times
are marked by violence and hate speech
against minorities
some politicians especially those with
ties to the governing bjp party are
accused of inciting and promoting that
violence
indian and global human rights watchdogs
say the frequency of attacks has been on
the rise since 2014. the year narendra
modi became prime minister
some opposition parties accuse him of
ignoring the issue and their warning
modi the fallout could devastate india's
cultural diversity
india's 13 main opposition parties
signed a statement saying we are
extremely concerned with the growing
incidents of hate speech in the country
by people who appear to have official
patronage and against whom no meaningful
and strong action is being taken
we strongly condemn the recent outburst
of communal violence witnessed across
several states we are deeply concerned
as reports indicate that there is a
sinister pattern in the areas where
these incidents have occurred
incendiary hate speeches preceded the
aggressive armed religious processions
unleashing communal violence
all hindu hardline leaders have held
meetings to discuss rising tensions
around hate speech directed against
muslims in recent days a spate of
incidents around the hindu festival of
ram navami have led to violence in some
states and india's supreme court is
hearing a motion for political rallies
that promote hate speech to be stopped
all right let's bring in our guests from
new delhi surancy mathal
baharatiya janata party leader and
author of rss building india through
sewer and from washington d.c
ahmed founder and ceo of the center for
countering digital hate and also from
new delhi sabha nagli an independent
journalist thank you all very much for
joining us here on inside story i'd like
to start with you uh saba sabanak vfa
may
as we've been saying dozens of videos
have been going viral on social media
since sunday showing processions of
hindu men some with sticks some with
swords um stopping at muslim
neighborhoods basically
looking to provocate to scare to
intimidate
just give our international audience a
sense of of of what the situation is
right now how bad is it
uh it's unprecedented there is a rash of
eight speech
uh hate processions
uh they are uh targeting mosques
uh they go and stand outside mosques
there are we can visibly see
uh
members of the procession trying to
enter the mosque and raise
and have a saffron flag over there there
have been speeches have been made
threatening the rape of muslim women
it's horrific it's unprecedented we are
a country which has known communal
violence between communities but what is
being allowed
these incidents have taken place in
seven indian states
as many as seven indian states and this
follows a sort of profiling of the hijab
the dress of uh
of a
section of the muslim community a
question over halal meat it follows
there is just that's the constant
campaigning right now there's constant
mobilization on identity issues and
mobilization
in a way which is scary and terrifying
for indian muslims which is a very very
large minority and one of the largest
populations in the world of the muslim
community
i i want to cross over to imran ahmed
who has a very uh particular
specialization in uh
things that happen online trolling
identity based hate misinformation
conspiracy theories modern extremism mr
ahmed how does
hate speech take such a hold where it
boils over into physical violence as
we've seen
it happening from from a psychological
standpoint how does it take hold like
that
well i think one of the things to
remember is that the people using social
media are human beings and the messages
they're receiving online
they are absorbing and and using in
their offline life too and that that
seems
sort of axiomatic and pretty
straightforward pretty obvious really
when you think about it
and
india's government at the moment has
shown a real aptitude for using the
various tools that digital platforms
primarily based in the united states
primarily using a united states rule set
and enforcement of their rules a very
poor enforcement of their rules to be
frank
um have given them which are the ability
to mass preservation
misinformation and hatred to
tens of millions of people hundreds of
millions of people at very rapid speed
for zero cost
and that's why these platforms which are
of course incredibly cheap to use
virtually nothing
are so powerful as a mechanism for
manipulation of the public
we'll talk a little bit later about uh
what's being done to try and combat that
but for now i'd like to cross over to
tsutanshi mattel so don't shoot metal
rather excuse me um the ruling bjp party
has been accused of not just allowing
this but of encouraging it hate speech
communal violence as a member of that
party what's your assessment what's your
reaction
i would reject the chance outright
but before i do that
what uh
i heard from sabah nakhmi is respectable
it is the most horrified
uh
lie
which is there to provoke
a communally charged environment
look how blatantly she's criminal
in in her outburst
against the people who themselves are
the victims
now here is a hindu festival which is
being celebrated and there's a shovayata
which is going
now stones are
stored peddling is taking place
the procession is attacked and look who
does she want to blame she wants to
blame the people who are celebrating
their own religious festival it is this
narrative which is the uh which has
resulted in what is happening
video which i believe we have we have
the video we have videos it's gone
around the world
no please
why is this one with you haven't you
seen the 50 videos where you have your
most storing stones where people uh
wearing muslim cats are sweating at the
police where they have swords their
knives in which they're stabbing haven't
you seen all these so are you rejecting
that's right
can i can i just ask the question are
you rejecting excuse me can you are you
rejecting outright that there is any
discrimination
communal violence happening targeting
the minorities which are in this case
we're talking about muslims absolutely
so you don't even think it exists
right right it's rejected outright and
like let's let's come down to the speech
also when one gentleman belonging to
the hindu
party was making a hate speech he was
arrested and he was not released for two
months
for two hours did you say he wasn't
released for two hours
right
no no this is completely wrong okay i
have the document here which shows that
he was in jail for two months
two months sorry that was like he was
put behind bar for two months right
right right yeah he was
and and you ever
who made the worst speech he says give
me 15 minutes and i will kill all the
hindus
he's out and he's been acquitted by a
state which is ruled by the opposition
okay so please
the problem is instead of being instead
of being equitable about
condemning anybody who takes law in his
own hands we have been taking sides to
paint a picture to to defame india
whereas the truth is that law of land
anybody who violates has to be punished
be the hindus be the muslims nobody has
the privilege of taking law in his own
hand sure and can you imagine this that
is the majority community cannot even
celebrate but just to be clear just to
be clear before we move on you're saying
that you do not think that there is such
thing as targeted violence happening
from hindu nationalists against the
muslim minority you just do not think
it's happening
there's nothing there is nothing called
hindu nationalists
sabanacv i'd like to bring you in and
just get your reaction to that if i may
look uh i i'd say that the issue is of
saving india's constitution india is a
secular country we have a fabulous
constitution and there is of course
denial there is uh we are told day in
and day out that
sort of the social media messaging is
that hindus are being attacked by
muslims muslims are attacking hindus to
get themselves killed arrested to hoist
the flags to stop to to raise questions
on them on their food on their dress no
but they they deserve it they are
provoking it anyway that's the kind of
typical trope of all right-wing ideology
and i do not want to
have a sort of a
fight or
it's it's gone beyond that the situation
is bad
it is deliberate it is not being stopped
and uh it has been it's seven
in a university in delhi one of india's
best universities students were beaten
up for eating meat on a particular day
because a section of the student said
we are doing a puja over here so you
cannot eat meat even though there is no
law about it beyond that homes of
muslims in the state of madhya pradesh
have been demolished uh on the grounds
that they threw stones at a procession
passing through now if you give me a
little bit of time india was always
negotiating the uh from the time of the
partition and our foundation the
processions going through certain areas
there was always a protocol for it it
was not allowed the police would not
allow certain processions to go through
certain areas
where other communities live all of that
is does not happen anymore what the
police does is that these processions
which are abusing a particular community
which are defaming their own religion by
the way if you hear the kind of language
no religion can be about that uh you
have these groups just going through
these areas abusing trying your visuals
again and again okay trying to climb on
to and let me just say two years ago in
delhi there were riots and as many as 14
mosques were attacked burnt
and 14 and let me say this on the record
it was all there small moss not big moss
in the city where i live it happened
here okay so let's not eat ourselves
because i'm not going to be
i hear you my role is to moderate and
make sure that we give we give equal
time to all of our panelists i can see
you raising your hands to rancho mattel
what did you want to add
again i said it is this kind of criminal
uh
hatred which is responsible for what is
happening today look at the state of
rajasthan which is ruled by the
opposition not bj
and you have procession
the processions were given permission by
congress
and she wants to blame us for this you
know this kind she's a muslim and this
kind of feminist outburst against the
hindus is largely responsible for
probably provoking her own community she
is giving them the feeling of victimhood
give me one instance where the
government of the day has destinated
against the muslims give me one sense
whether the government
or any other states have given one favor
to the hindus they have looked at the
constitution and said everybody is equal
i think we can have we can every
system we can try and have you give us
time we can try and have a constructive
debate we have sabanacv on as an
independent journalist
her religion or otherwise is not is not
part of this discussion i'd like to
cross over now to imran ahmed if i may
are people
and i'm not just talking about india i'm
talking about in general are people
manipulated to increase polarization or
are our actors capitalizing on fear and
anger
that already exists
well i mean one of the things that's
changed in the last few years is the
elevation
of that which differs us from that which
unites us and the elevation as well in
negative partisanships the amount of
campaigning which is based on hatred of
another
and that's primarily based on the fact
that we've shifted a lot of our
discourse a lot of our political
discussion to platforms that
specifically target
and amplify elevate that which is most
contentious because it's contentious
keeps us on the platforms
and over 10 years we've indulged in an
experiment around the world as to what
would happen if we network 4.5 billion
people and then increase the temperature
and you get the kind of you know you see
negative partisanship rising around the
world people hate the other party more
than they like their own you see you see
the the the sort of the the competitive
advantage that hateful speech gives
to political parties and this is just
this this is a an epi phenomenon this
this desiccated debate right now
yeah is an epi phenomenon of a broader
problem and
in one respect
listening to sort of you know one side
which is essentially if if if for
example the indian government
did care about hate speech then it would
be doing a lot more than it's doing at
the moment i mean it's argument seems to
be we're doing nothing
you know to either solve or or to
exacerbate
you can believe for yourself whether or
not you believe that's true
and i mean
and of course that comes with a a set of
political behaviors i mean we've seen
this played out this could be ukraine
right now this could be a putin puppet
talking right now on one side of the
ukrainian activist on the other side
this could be
democrats and republicans under trump it
could be brexit and remain under
uh uh
six years ago when i first started
studying this topic it could be right
now a supporter of le pen or macron in
france it as desiccated and familiar a
trope now that we pull out a defender of
hatred on social media and someone who
represents the victims of that hatred on
social media when in fact what we should
be focusing on
is that social media itself
and the dynamics and the economics that
underpin the dynamics of those platforms
is the problem no matter what sort of
pound shop putin has to say about it
i want to ask you you raised a very good
point and made some very good um
analogies i'd like to ask you sabanacv
what has the indian government done or
not done what has narendra modi said
about this issue
after the recent round of violence he
has said nothing uh there has been an
arrest uh today in delhi of uh of a
leader of a group called the vishwa
hindu parisha i just like to make one
point i'm i am a political journalist i
have a book out on the bjp i've
interviewed uh the former prime minister
i even interviewed uh
mr narendra modi before he became chief
minister and of course he does not give
press conferences and all so i am not
somebody it is i have been forced to use
my social media presence my columns to
highlight what i think is going wrong in
the country i'm not there i'm not there
as an activist speaking only for a
community and there's a journalist
watching my constitutional values
just get destroyed so i'd like to make
that very clear and i know mr sudanshu
mittal we have met each other i know all
most of the people in the pgp are known
to me
so you know so this is not that simple
as it some of us are being fought and he
sits and says she is a muslim she is a
muslim you know which is when i
interrupted because like i said like
like i said the point the point is not
where we are wanting to descend into
personal attacks that this is not the
forum
to have constructive discussions
so i just want to come back and that is
why we brought you on the program as an
independent journalist i just want to
come back to that question we hear you i
want to come back to that question what
has narendra modi done to
well what has he said about this whole
issue
in this time he has said nothing in fact
the opposition leaders a lot of them
have issued a letter saying are we to
live in a state of permanent
polarization and can the prime minister
please speak up and stop this nothing
has been said so far what he has done in
the past is he has a slogan which goes
as sad sub kavikas which means with all
for everyone development for everyone so
that slogan is said that the prime
minister represents that that is how the
bjp does its political messaging but on
the ground all of this happens
all of this
particularly right now
in a sort of alarming way
and all like my all right right-minded
indians and there are many be of any
religion
are out there raising this issue today
sure sudanshu matal uh i can see you
you'd want you want to respond please go
ahead
firstly the law and order
is a state subject and it is not
controlled by the center
so what was
said
by the earlier speaker as well as uh
that
government is not doing anything about
it there is a law in existence which
punishes anything which is
uh hateful and which is beyond the what
is guaranteed under the constitution
under the freedom of speech so that's
the first point second point
ani kwik vocally mr naren modi the prime
minister has so many times
condemned
any any hate speech by anybody the only
difference is he doesn't make a
differentiation he doesn't say muslims
have no right he does not say hinduism
he says no indian has any right to take
law in his own hand or any hate speech
can be permitted nor will take its own
course the moment anybody violates the
law so as far as constitution is
concerned that's the sacred book which
this government has been upholding
thirdly
please understand that the writings have
taken place in states which are largely
governed by the opposition rajasthan it
has happened in
uh
[Music]
to say you know to now portray that this
is a design by the government where is
the design give me one statement by the
government either of the
state or the senator ruled by bjp which
discriminated which says we will permit
anybody to take on his own hand
we have always fought by the
constitution that's what we have been
first she herself has
today considered that one person
belonging to a religious group for hindu
religious groups
i hear what you're saying i hear what
you're saying
i hear what you're saying that that the
message is that no one is above the law
regardless of their uh
of their religious beliefs i i hear what
you're saying i'd like to cross over to
imran ahmed
rights groups have asked facebook to
release a report into hate speech in
india which it commissioned in 2020 it
hasn't been released i want to come back
to that essential question of how much
responsibility do social networks
bear well i mean
they won't release the report because it
will be a devastating indictment of
their failure to enforce their own
community standards
and of course they bear responsibility i
mean when you are aware of a problem
when you allow that problem to happen
and you continue to profit from that
problem happening
you're pretty liable aren't you
vicariously for the harm that's been
created
and i mean i think that's one of the
biggest problems that we face
in the world right now is that we have a
lack of accountability and
responsibility for things that are said
online
i mean every now and then someone will
get pulled onto a tv show
where they'll bluster and lie about how
they haven't been encouraging hate
speech when in fact everyone knows they
have and the net effect of their social
media presence is to increase the amount
of threat against innocent people
and i think that that we have to look at
the actual platforms themselves and see
how we can hold them accountable in the
united states we have section 230 of the
communications decency at 1996 which
actually prohibits platforms
from being held liable for
third-party speech on their sites and
there are a number of different ideas
for how that could be changed for
example that liability shield might be
removed where there are serious human
rights violations that's something that
roe khanna for example the congressman
from california has suggested there's
even been people saying we should remove
that shield entirely so that platforms
can be held liable
because the toll
the toll
for their indifference
and for their lazy greedy
monetization of hate speech
and enabling of hate speech is of course
felt in deaths it's felt in lives lost
the pandemic for example in which
millions of people died thanks to
misinformation spread on their platforms
whether that be the rohingya muslim in
burma whether that be the people of
ukraine now because let's not forget in
that conflict in the ukraine right now
the first weapons the russians deployed
were not missiles and tanks they were
lies and misinformation and that
playbook is actually the most
sophisticated the bjp is one of the
biggest super producers of
misinformation and lies about muslims
worldwide
now that has a net effect on humanity
i'm sorry
sir
i'm sorry i have to interrupt we cannot
we cannot i'm letting him have his say
and as the as the moderator here you
have to accept that he is sharing his
analysis with us and do you know what
actually my apologies but that is time
so we're going to have to leave it there
all right hey thank you very much to all
of our guests sudanshi mattel imran
ahmed and saba nakhvi and thank you two
for watching you can see the program
again any time by visiting our website
al jazeera.com and for further
discussion go to our facebook page
that's facebook.com forward slash aj
inside story you can also join the
conversation on twitter our handle is at
aj inside story from me kim vanel the
whole team here in doha bye for now
you